sham sharanya is joining us here on the
rich eisen show
from the bubble and he is one of the
best in the business
not only because he knows his stuff but
he works for two organizations how are
you shams
rich i'm good hope you're doing well and
uh congrats on the move
hey i appreciate you saying that and um
as you know
you you know um there is a brave new
world out there
uh of so many different ways that you
can get your information out there
you you know that firsthand and you're
doing that from the bubble for the
athletic as well as
stadium so let's talk about um
life in the bubble how long have you
been there and how long are you are you
there for the duration
yeah rich so i actually just got here uh
late uh last night
okay i'm just not starting the process
i'll be here
i'm planning through the duration of the
remainder of the playoffs so
i guess i'm here for the good stuff and
and i'm looking forward to it obviously
it's a
it's an unprecedented moment in our
history it's a
very unique historic opportunity um but
yeah i'll be quarantined i think for the
next seven days so i'll be i'll be
in my room so you're in the entry portal
essentially
to the bubble before you're basically
yeah i'm in the i'm in the entry
hotel and then pass the test and then
hopefully get into the bubble and then
there's another quarantine period so
the nba has definitely done everything
they can to make sure that there is no
entry or infection level that spreads so
i'm i'm feeling that uh part of that
firsthand right now are you literally
i'm serious now are you literally stuck
in a hotel room
for a week like you cannot leave that
room that door and they and you
and they are monitoring whether you are
or not is that what's happening
i i don't know i don't know if they're
monitoring me but
you know i mean listen there have been a
couple players that have left quarantine
and and then they have to and then they
just have to deal with additional days
of quarantine right and like
bruno caboclo rashawn holmes couple guys
that have broken
you know level of protocol really early
in the process and then they ended up
having to quarantine an additional 10
days
i don't want to do that to myself so i'm
gonna i'm going to stay on myself i'm
going to monitor myself richard
all right shame sharon you're here on
the rich eisen show let's get
into it um more or so the a big exhale
by uh laker fandom
um what to what do you
attest the difference between games one
and two or the entire bubble experience
and then game two last night
i don't know you can say this is a stark
difference but when anthony davis shows
up at that level you know he's had a
couple big games so far in the bubble
but then he's also had some games where
he might be a little less aggressive a
little less effective you know those
eight
nine point ten point games that's not
going to cut it for these lakers they
need him to be dominant
um night in and night out and i think
last night was a good step in that
direction
he didn't bring it in game one to the
level that we expect out of anthony
davis and i think
that's something that lebron james is
knowing the leader he is he's going to
continue to stress that on anthony davis
and continue to try to get the best out
of him but
um this team will only go as far as
lebron james anthony davis can take them
and the role players stepping up as well
and
i think that was the biggest sign that
you can take from game game two well i
mean that and also i guess
the dislocated left index finger of
damian lillard the outside of i guess
you would say maybe even devin booker
the hottest player
um in the bubble since it had been
created
and there was a tip-off within it and um
it just maybe gets that sense that the
run of the the blazers um took
a considerable hit even though there are
no broken bones what what what do you
make of this
development yeah so he he has a
dislocated finger
and and like he said last night there is
a level of pain
there's some swelling um but listen he's
he's from
i spoke to someone close to him last
night he's from the town the person said
so he's going to play
in game three and and he's he's
optimistic that
giving a couple days off and and
continue to treat that finger he'll be
he'll be fine but you know that step
back to his left hand
and and being able to shoot it it's
gonna have an effect
the question is how big of an effect
it's going to happen we're not going to
know until he gets on the floor game
three
um if it starts to affect his reign his
ability step back ability to dribble
with the left hand then you're going to
see
a major difference in a big big blow to
this portland roster which obviously he
has been
the mvp so far of the bubble no doubt
about that and you know
obviously milwaukee had a bounce back
game interestingly enough the
the one seeds each scoring 111 points in
their bounce back games to
uh even up a series at one a piece um as
they beat orlando
last night and so what about westbrook
do we see russell westbrook at all what
can you tell us about his
injury and how long we might see him on
the bench for the rockets who are up 2-0
on oklahoma city
yeah russell westbrook i'm told is
progressing he is
every day doing a little little bit more
um you know
early this week he was stand still
shooting i think
i've been told middle of this week and
in
yesterday and today he's gonna start to
at least jump a little bit more on his
jump on a shot and
do a little bit more so every day is a
level of progress
there was some hope within the team that
there might be a chance for them to come
back this weekend
but again up too oh they have the
cushion right now
um there's no real need to rush russell
westbrook back and i think the rockets
understand that i think they will be
very very cautious um with how they
they monitor his return but he wants to
play i think
there's going to be shock um around the
thunder for sure if russell
doesn't find his way back down back on
the floor at some point in the series
and so um what's the sixers future
looking like
we talked about it with your colleague
from sports illustrated chris mannix
yesterday that
that um the process that's been trusted
might not be as trustworthy or trustable
uh anymore that this is the end of the
process that we have reached the end of
it and i know that simmons is hurt but
simmons and
mb didn't seem to mix very well prior to
um the pandemic so where do you stand on
the sixers
right now yeah you know
they're going to have decisions to make
at the end of the season um
you know on different situations whether
you look at the coaching staff whether
you look
you know different parts of the front
office but you know
ben simmons joel embiid those are two
talents that you will not
you know it's hard-pressed to find right
when you have them and when you have
them secured for multi-year long-term
deals
the goal is to keep them and and for
everything i've been told
you know the sixers are still
prioritizing the future around ben
simmons and joel embiid
if that means maybe finding someone else
to help steer the ship
i think that a franchise would rather do
that and turn things over
to someone that might be able to make it
work you you give this
as much of an opportunity as you can
because talent like this
just doesn't come around so if you feel
like you have to entrust a new coach
or whatever you have to do to make sure
that you see this through
uh that is still my sense that that is
what they are hopeful of doing
so um sham charania of uh uh the
athletic and stadium joining me here
on the rich eisen show do we see mike
conley for the
utah jazz i mean we get a tip off um in
short order for the tip off of the
quadruple header with toronto at
brooklyn
um in about an hour's time but do we see
mike conley for the jazz after that in
that game three
yeah i mean the the goal is for mike
conley jr to return today he's been
quarantining for four plus days
and uh he he's gonna be back in the
lineup uh he's expecting to play
and you know it'll be interesting to see
how that meshes with this jazz roster
which has succeeded for the most part
in both games they played they had a
chance to win game one as well and
absolutely crushed denver in game two
and dominic mitchell has really played
well
at point guard and he's he's really uh
relished this opportunity to have the
ball in his hands
how will that uh impact his game with
mike comey jr back in the lineup um i
think that's a question that is
that utah's been trying to get a grip on
all season long and
now it's going to be game three question
okay
so let's uh let's um talk about
tonight's game between the
clippers and and mavericks i mean uh
it's now a five game series
uh this is exciting uh luca it does not
appear that the clippers have an answer
for him
um when he is either not banged up or in
foul trouble
and uh as long as porzingis stays out of
the crosshairs of the officials it looks
like th
this is um this is the maverick series
to take what do you think
they're they're going to have a shot
here and i think one more thing rich
no patrick beverly and you saw the way
that he really went out luca the first
few minutes
of game one you could tell luca was in
for a really really long series a tough
series of physical series and
patrick beverly has had this calf
problem he wrestled the calf issue
during seating games
it's not flared up again and uh he's
doubtful to play today and so that is a
big shot to the clippers defensive line
up and
um i think a positive for the mavericks
so they have a shot here
to make this competitive uh the series
competitive i don't know if they win
this
they but they definitely have a shot
here um in the mavic's first run with
this
luca doctor's present for zingers
pairing in the in the playoffs now would
be
just an absolute disaster it's it's just
amazing how things work like you think
the lakers are in trouble now you think
the clippers are in trouble and who
knows maybe they wind up in a western
conference finals in that bubble anyway
but um just the way that the certainly
with hardaway junior looking the way
that he's looking and the rest of the
team contributing
i i you get the sense that the clippers
um
without beverly and harold needing to
get his feet under him
that they're they're in trouble you got
that i just get that sense and it would
definitely be
helpful if they had you know an actual
staples center to get the fans uh
getting them moving but um you just get
that sense that if if porzingis didn't
get
uh ejected or be silly enough to get
into that set to in game one this could
be an o2 hole that the clippers are in
right now
very yeah i mean that's it very well
could be and
and but you know listen i expect paul
george will be better
um you know he's he he had a rough go in
game two
i think he'll come back motivated and
ready for game three and
i would expect him to step his game up i
would expect kawhi to be kawhi
listen the clippers still have the edge
here um as far as i feel
and uh but listen the mavericks know pat
beverly i think that only helps luke
dodge it's the domination
of the floor any idea when beverly could
be coming back
with cass rich i think it's all up in
the air it really just depends day to
day he missed several weeks
in seating games um to rest and get
better
um it really as far as i'm told a
day-to-day situation based on treatment
okay um all right let's get to the uh
the draft lottery
um last night the timberwolves when the
2020 draft
draft lottery and so um
this means attempt with the warriors and
then the hornets right behind him
um what a what a position for the
warriors but i guess
for the timberwolves they take who who
do you think it's going to be
i you know it's a great question you
know i spoke to someone close to the
situation last night
they're still looking at all names i
don't think you can rule anything out
i mean obviously anthony edwards from a
positional standpoint makes a lot of
sense
you heard a lot of talk about anthony
edwards around the league but
this is a process rich that this is
unprecedented what's going on right now
in pre-in the pre-draft process
these are you know league executives
this is not what they're accustomed to
so
it's going to be a very patient process
you know have a virtual draft combine
most likely in september
see what more information the intel you
can gather and try to make the best
decision i
i'm sure minnesota will receive calls on
the first pick as well but
um yeah i think anthony edwards right
now uh positionally makes some sense
obi topping is another name that that
you hear executives on the league
point at as a candidate there um i don't
know if james wiseman
is the fit i don't know if lamelo balls
would fit there given they have the
angel russell
um but you know those are the a couple
names that i was here right off the bat
so basically the warriors signed
d'angelo russell right
they get wiggins and then they get the
second overall pick
anyway i mean you know you know what i'm
saying like and
so they they have the treasure they have
the flexibility and they have now the
health
what i mean what's the rest of the leak
thinking they must be
they must be freaking out a little bit
right
i mean the warriors as long as they're
healthy and these guys come back in top
form
say thompson steph curry draymond green
obviously this is going to be a tough
team
and assuming you know if anthony edwards
goes one
um you know the warriors you know james
wiseman is a guy that makes a lot of
sense for them
and so you bring in wiseman you have him
and and you
have a team that's ready to go and
there's going to be veteran players
across the league that want to join this
team
um some players that i know have been
looking at them as a destination
um because you want to be a part of
something like this and so
they're going to be right back in the
thick of this next season i'm sure well
drop some names
give me some names who might want to
join the warriors and just go ahead and
make them a 60-win team
once again in two seconds flat
i don't know i don't know if i can spill
any names yet rich what do you mean
you're in the bubble no one's listening
you're in the rich eyes in show bubble
we'll just keep it between us
come on now what do you got
man i got nothing oh boy
but you're hearing already that players
once they are free
of this 2019-2020 season
would be more than happy to throw
themselves in the city
i mean you always have veteran players
that are coming up on pages that begin
prioritizing you know championships and
wanting to be on contending teams and
seeing different fit opportunities
because you know this warriors team
besides the core guys
there's going to be some roster turnover
um on this on this team they're going to
have some open spots here
on the bench and things like that so um
definitely i think they're you know
it's an appealing location appealing
destination all right charms
thanks for the call uh be safe hope you
are uh fully
injected into the bubble uh safe and
sound and enjoy the rest of the way
we'll call you
uh we'll call you up as the the weeks
progress
and the season continues and the
championship possibilities uh
dwindle for some teams and and blossom
we appreciate the time
sounds good rich thank you again thank
you same to you that's uh champs
charania
of uh the athletic as well as stadium
joining us here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here